abajo hay pares ordenados que
representan los seis primeros términos
de dos patrones el primer valor en cada
par es un término del patrón
y el segundo valor es un término del
patrón ver en la caja de respuestas hay
diferentes afirmaciones acerca de los
dos patrones dice selecciona todas las
afirmaciones correctas entonces vamos a
pensar y pondremos información
importante nos dice que el patrón am
será el primer valor de cada par
entonces consideremos que el patrón am
será 1 2 4 8 16 y 32 que de hecho si nos
damos cuenta pareciera que si vamos de
un término a otro estaríamos
multiplicando por 2 1 por 2 es igual a 2
2 x 2 es igual a 4 por lo tanto se
repite este patrón 4 por 2 es igual a 8
y así en cada uno de estos términos
estaremos multiplicando por 2
y lo ven ahora nos dice que el segundo
valor es un término del patrón b vamos
entonces a marcar el patrón d
voy a cambiarle el color porque este
creo que no se alcanza a ver muy bien
patrón de estamos igual dejémoslo en
verde el patrón b entonces será este
segundo número que si nos damos cuenta
siempre será 3
que de hecho podemos decir que hemos
sumado 0 en cada uno de estos
movimientos y siempre nos dará 33 más
eres igual a 33 más eres igual a tres o
incluso podemos pensar que estamos
multiplicando por 13 por 1 me dará 3
3 por 1 otra vez será 3 3 por 1 será 3 y
siempre tendremos 3
lo ven así es que vamos a ver nuestra
información y tomaremos algunas
decisiones dice que en el patrón a se
puede llegar desde cualquier término al
siguiente al multiplicar por un número
constante y si de hecho si nos damos
cuenta aquí en cada uno de estos
términos hemos multiplicado por dos y el
número dos es una constante así es que
vamos a considerar éste como correcto
nos dice que el siguiente par debería de
ser 52 3
veamos si nosotros traemos un patrón de
multiplicar por dos en
los términos del patrón a 32 por 2 será
igual a 64
y si consideramos el patrón b
multiplicaremos una vez más 3 por 1
nos dará igual a 3 así es que el
resultado correcto será 64 32 52 3 por
lo que éste será
un enunciado incorrecto vamos con el
tercero nos dicen que si grafica mos los
pares los puntos estarán en la misma
línea vamos a graficar veamos si esto es
correcto tendremos un eje vertical
y tendremos un eje horizontal donde el
eje horizontal será el patrón
mientras que el eje vertical será el
patrón b
y entonces buscaremos graficar todos
estos puntos tenemos hasta 32 en el
patrón am así es que si hago mi mejor
esfuerzo
la mitad de ellos era 16 la mitad de
esos eran 8 la mitad de eso se da 4 la
mitad de eso será 2 y la mitad de eso
será 1 de esta manera tendremos hasta el
número 32 dentro del patrón
y nosotros graficar hemos en el patrón
20 pues únicamente
un término que será 3 así es que vamos a
graficar tendremos entonces que cuando
el patrón tiene un valor de 1
el patrón d
tendrá un valor de 3 así es que vamos al
13 marcaremos aquí el punto cuando tiene
un valor de 2 b tendrá el valor de 3 2 y
23 en vez cuando a tiene un valor de 4
de tendrá valor de 3 metal o porque la
cabeza me está pensando aquí cuando
tendrá un valor de 8 que tendrá un valor
de 3 así es que vamos a 8,3
cuando tiene un valor de 16 b tendrá
valor de 3 vamos a 16 3
y cuando tenga un valor de 32
que tendrá un valor de 3
y si nos damos cuenta si efectivamente
se encuentra en una línea vamos a marcar
esta línea y seguramente la ven aquí
bueno con blanco se ve muy mal vamos a
cambiar el color
una línea que estará
aquí de acuerdo a los puntos que hemos
graficado así es que podemos considerar
la siguiente información que tenemos si
gráfica mos los pares los puntos estarán
en la misma línea esto es correcto
finalmente nos dice que en el patrón b
se pueden llegar desde cualquier término
al siguiente al multiplicar por un
número constante y de hecho sí porque
siempre estamos multiplicando por 1
3 por 11 3 por 11 3 por 11 siempre
estamos multiplicando por 1 y en este
caso específico 1 es nuestra constante
así es que tomaremos también este valor
como correcto de tal manera que sólo
tenemos uno de estos enunciados como
incorrecto el segundo donde nos dice que
el siguiente valor debía de haber sido
52 3 cuando realmente el siguiente valor
debió de haber sido 64 3